I got serious coyote problems.
I have,
I have no more chickens.
Really.
You're out of job.
All my chickens in one fell swoop.
You ready for this?
They killed the last nine chickens.
I had to transfer to them them cause my,
my um,
chicken coop burned to the ground.
So we had to get a smaller coop.
And you're blaming that on the co no,
no.
Um,
we,
the chickens escaped and we saved the chickens and we got them to this other
coop,
um,
after the fire.
And uh,
it wasn't as reinforced as the original coupe,
the original coupe.
I had hired a guy who's a carpenter to build me a nice coupe and he did a great
job and the coyotes were on the roof one night chewing at it.
And I had a fucking,
I had a,
a death perch set up on my porch.
I had my Hoyt out there.
I had arrows,
range finder.
I even had,
I even laid bait out in my yard waiting for these comments.
I was ready.
I was Rambo,
but I lost my patients and I'm a busy man.
I got a lot of things to do.
So I abandoned the project.
Fire came along,
fire burnt my fucking chicken coop down to the ground.
We put these uh,
chickens and another coop in these coyotes tour,
that coop part and they did it when we weren't home.
And uh,
we came home was just feathers.
They were all gone.
All nine of them there,
you know,
part of me admires them,
part of me is like these little wolves are surviving in the suburbs is trying to
figure this shit out.
Man.
They will break into this thing or die.
My wife was getting uncomfortable because you're basically making your house at
target.
You know,
they're on the roof right next to the house.
These little small predators are chewing at the roof of that.
The chicken coop before the fire happened and it was like,
oh that was the one I decided to go to war.
I didn't fully committed to war cause I didn't get a,
I was going to get a subsonic 22.
That's the way to go.
Cause it you're here subtonic 22 it sounds like says pack pack doesn't sound
like anything but it's lethal.
I and a coyote but I don't think it's legal inside city limits.
Like I don't even think I should be saying that I wanted to shoot it.
No,
with a,
with a rifle,
it's probably like a,
like a criminal intent idea.
But I never really considered it and I definitely never bought one.
But I was ready to fuck one up with a bow and arrow.
But uh,
now it's over.
They got,
they won,
they figured it out,
the fire opened up the door and they,
um,
after the fire was they were real sketchy,
real loud and cause they were trying to figure out what the fuck is going on
because like all the,
the brush was gone.
So probably the rabbits were missing and the rats are miss of course.
Yeah.
We're going to say Jamie.
Yeah,
it was a,
it's weird.
It came,
you know,
came home and see just feathers everywhere man.
Just feathers.
Like just like someone just sliced a few pillows and just shook 'em all over the
yard.
Like,
fuck,
you know.